what's up everybody welcome to riffing
with Griffin as a special solo episode I
hope you enjoyed last week's episode
last time on Griffin with Griffin we had
Russell Peters that was a great episode
and that was my 25th episode so now
we're into the last 75 towards 100 if I
can't even make it to a hundred but just
to say that I had 25 solid episodes of
doing the show is just like amazing I
want to thank everybody for being on the
ride with me I love saying that you're
on the journey and now returning here to
the new riffin with Griffin Studios
riffin Studios I need a name and of
course I'm looking for like artwork you
know to me look I got like this is make
sure it looks nice make sure it looks
nice and all that but yeah this is the
rhythm we're Griffi Studios like I got a
picture of Ralph I got like a Montez
poster I got my fish in posters I'm
gonna tell you if they're real or not
mmm I got like this is me playing
basketball when I was in high school you
know there's there's a meet with the
Clippers I was like the courtside
captain one day and so it's like Blake
Griffin and Chris Paul so you know as
you see I'm a big clipper fan I play
video games you know I got all my
clipper stuff here then I played like
video games
there's my Sakura video game I got there
for free want to think of people to send
me that you know I got excuse me I got a
call at duty anyway workaholics DVDs you
know I got everything right here I'm
dying up here and all the my little
Ralph thing so yeah um we're here we're
from Griffith studios you know so I I'm
eventually gonna like I had this Pele
box I'm gonna put that out there so if I
only was gonna put the peel box like if
people want to send me stuff they the
art cause like the music that I've been
getting one of the things that I've been
doing on this show is the theme songs
and like people been sending me
outstanding theme songs I I can't even
believe the talent level of the people
that send me these songs they're so good
and so I'm wondering about but you're
just people that have like a equivalent
of like art you know so if you got some
art out there you want to send you hey
you know what I'm about put it here but
we'll rotate it out you know but I just
want to say like thank you everybody for
listening and liking and commenting even
the haters I love the the haters helped
me too even though I do crack back
sometimes I gotta stop doing that but
you know I'm loving riff from what
Griffin and it's growing
I'm trying to figure out like what's the
how to do this what's the right way to
do it it's it's such a such a job it's
such a such a rewarding experience and
so this is my 26th episode and it's a
special episode because I want to
actually play all the theme songs most
of the theme songs that I've gotten
because I want to have like I'm gonna
put a Twitter poll up and then we'll
just figure out like who's the best
producer is not necessarily the best
song like because I've gotten multiple
songs from some people and then the
winner I'm a cinema a DVD yeah we old
school this is my first special the ugly
truth and I still have the DVDs I have a
bunch of these so the winners gonna get
this I'll sign it and then they'll get
that sign I have a couple more of these
ponies montes posters you know it's like
the car from that remember the car yet
with who when he was getting uh when she
was doing maintenance from the passenger
seat and then I gots movies right here
so if you wanna like this this dis art
that somebody made and just old school
contest but this is example of like the
kind of art that people send so you know
I want to put put that out there for you
guys to do if you want to send in and
I'll send it out to like I said to the
winner so we'll have that contest at the
end so throughout the few things that
I'm gonna talk about in this episode I
just have a couple of things cuz I
haven't done a solo episode in a
long-ass time because I've been doing
all these interviews and I love all the
interviews and that's actually what I
want to talk about first you know what I
mean is all these great interviews that
I've gotten but even before that I want
to have the theme song for today's
episode let's start with a theme song
y'all and remember on Griffin with
Griffin out we got the yeah so that's
the nonsense we're gonna be doing all
riffing what Griffin I got a singing mic
y'all so hope you enjoy that but first
up before we start the episode episode
2016 as good is from my good buddy Ben C
word man made the the theme songs for my
both my specials the ugly truth
and American warrior which you could buy
the ugly truth on Erik Griffin calm I'll
sign it yeah so you made the theme songs
for both those specials and he also made
the music for my queen you can look that
up to look up my queen this is a music
video I made as montes for Colleen you
know what I haven't put the link down to
it there's still up some place so you
guys can watch that but this is the guy
that made that Ben C word he's my dude
and so today's first theme we're gonna
go over cuz you guys you guys haven't
even heard this one yet first thing
before we start talking about stuff in
this episode is from Ben Siebert and we
for sure gonna need to sing in my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's my boy my boy band see were Ben see
were came with the hot arm be fire
because that's what he does he can make
actually any kind of music so if you
need if you need some music done you
should hit up in guys people that are
listening you're like who made that
track this guy you give him a reference
track and he'll come up with some [ __ ]
he's great but anyways first up on this
episode a MIT I throat y'all first
episode first thing I want to talk about
in this episode of it from a Griffin is
all the great guests that I've had in
the first twenty five and actually
starting with like in the last the last
person I just had on the show was
Russell Peters you know we had a great
talk he's fun to talk to so make sure
you listen to that one you know I had
Tony rock on the show we had a great
discussion about his family just hearing
his upbringing being in the rock family
brother of Chris Rock you know I always
used to wonder like why they never like
you never see them around together you
never see them doing shows and stuff
like that it's because they had this
weird work ethic that they got from not
weird
they had a great work I think they got
from their parents to like strive and do
things on your own
don't rely on anybody so they both kind
of had this like rise you know and
Tony's going through this thing right
now and just hearing about them having
like this strong black father in the
household I'm not surprised at the you
know the that they've had some the giant
success that they had so that's a great
episode so listen to the Tony Rock
episode I had Tiffany Haddish on Tiffany
was on it was great you know she's so
big right now I've known her forever so
she she graced to my presence you know
grace to show by coming on and I thought
that was really
generous of her all the workaholics
people I love all them Blake was my
Blake Anderson was my first guest and I
just have a real fondness for Blake he's
such a sweet dude and he came on and we
talked and it was just like it just it
made me feel so comfortable because I
didn't know how I was gonna be having a
guest you know so he was my first guest
so all the workaholics people have been
great on ders Kyle the ladies of
workaholics Jillian and Marybeth I loved
having them on you know they're real
they're real cool people too so you know
it's just all the guests I've had have
just been great tone Bell Brianne Howie
she was one of my favorites because she
was on work she was on um I'm dying up
here with me and you know she's like a
my mom my Hollywood crush you know what
I mean
god I love it but she got a boyfriend
shoutout to Doogie his name is I really
do you bet I love calling him Doogie I
think he's like a doctor he's like a
lawyer
but I always think he's a doctor cuz you
get just really she's get just really
like like babyface you know you know
he's got this babyface so I just I love
that um but anyway they're great and so
there was a lot of really great episodes
and I have more to come but you know I
said you know what let's do some solo
episodes like why haven't I done solo
episodes in a while because like I said
I've had all these great guests so but
there's like a lot of stuff going on in
the world since since I've had my last
solo EPS I think the last solo episode I
have it I was talking about Kevin Hart
you know and it's great cuz he was just
on Rogan and he was talking about the
the Oscars thing and I think he's he's
still handling it great you know what I
mean just it's what are you supposed to
do we live in a really sensitive time
she can't say anything without people
flying off the handle and here's my
thing about it I get apologizing like if
you say something inappropriate or you
say something that it's not even
necessarily inappropriate but somebody
finds it inappropriate or somebody takes
offense
I'm fine with being like I'm sorry that
you took offense that I'm sorry that my
words hurt you as long as you can
acknowledge that wasn't my intention you
know cuz that's not what's coming back
on the other side like when for
comedians say guys I'm saying like
comedians are making jokes and they're
saying things but now [ __ ] Road
scholars you know what I mean we're just
we're making jokes about you know things
and then we want to put it out there and
then because of social media and their
YouTube and all this stuff people are
grabbing it and putting it out you know
it's like the what happens in the comedy
club sometimes to me should stay in the
comedy club because that's why you came
there for that so but you know when
things get out and you know in the
public and you say things publicly or
you say things on specials that people
don't like you know it's like obviously
we meant it in jest uh yeah and I know
that yes you you might have taken
offense yes you might have gotten hurt
but damn do it does it have to be like
you think I'm a horrible person because
of that no I think you should just go
hey you made a joke and I know you
didn't mean for it to be way it was
taken but it it was taken this way if we
have a back-and-forth that way I think
we'll won't be able to enjoy comedy
again you know I mean look at me I'm
already talking about stuff all right
well that it's not even what I wanted to
do but I did anyway so shout out to
Kevin Hart and Joe Rogan for having a
great discussion about that stuff but
okay let's go back to a theme song so
first we have been all right next up we
got Brandon horn this is the great
Brandon horn to see what he got for us
I'm not sure if he's in the running yet
cuz I'm gonna have like five six maybe
five or six maybe seven and we'll do a
Twitter poll but here's Brandon horn
[Music]
casting spells at the club team if you
showed up I would a wander to the club
riff riff debrife mr. Griffith this
one's dope so shout out to Brandon
let me listen to the talent yeah all
right so that's Brandon Horne
we love that one let's go with one more
well good we'll go to in between each
topic so that was Brandon Horne if you
like that one and here's a Brian Hanna
another by another B guy Wow
oh I see I'm like was all these bees
because I have it in laughs abetik order
okay so we got there was Ben and then we
got Brandon Horne and now we have Brian
Hanna
see what Brian's got for us oh we might
need to sing in mind all right that was
Brian Hanna shout out to Brian Hanna
that was dope thank you Brian
all right let's go to the rhythm with
Griffin notebook okay so we talked about
the theme songs so what we gonna do I
did my hello hello intro hi this is Eric
Griffin I'm still at all things comedy
guys don't don't think I left there just
not doing it on in Burbank anymore I'm
still doing it at Burbank actually I
have a couple scheduled cuz you know I
don't want everybody coming to my place
um they're my favorite my favorite
episodes even some more like Dane Cook I
thought was a really great episode you
know I was talking to him for months I
was like Dane you should come on mine
come on I'm doing this podcast I'd love
for you to be a guest and he was like
you know kind of ducking me about it for
a long time and then he's like all right
I'll come on and he was great he just
loved talking you know and he's actually
on the ground floor that because he used
to do this thing called
stream-of-consciousness on his website
like he was doing podcast before anybody
was doing podcast right that's what the
the modern podcast is what that was but
like then all of us
sudden he comes on my podcast I think oh
[ __ ] I got the exclusive dr. Dane Cook
exclusive this [ __ ] three days
later on CEOs podcast he's been on Birds
podcast he's on Bobby's podcast he did
it killed Tony he actually did to kill
Tony before mine but this kind of format
you know what I mean it's a deal
you know but it's cool he's a he's a
great dude people he's still polarizing
him because people love to love Dane
Cook and they love to hate him because
they love loving hating Dane Cook so
check out that episode cuz it's a really
good episode all right back to the
different what Griffin notebook like I
said I haven't done a solo in a while
said a lot of things have been going on
in the world and one of them that I
never got to talk about that I wanted to
is that Jesse's small that I'll be quick
so I know the people been talking about
this at nauseam but I'm glad it happened
because people in the world need to
understand why we have due process we
have due process for a reason because
you can't just believe anything that
anybody says you take it serious you go
through the investigation you find out
the facts you take a measured approach
and then you like make a make come out
with like okay here's our findings you
know but with the court of public
opinion in social media people just put
things out and then all of a sudden like
you know people like oh you know oh man
and they're on their Twitter like
outraged by this you know people loved
it like let people know how they feel
they they go on their Twitter and it's
crazy because Twitter like the
Washington Post and like New York Times
places like this they have actually you
know they're accountable for what they
say there's accountability like you
can't just say whatever the [ __ ] you
want to say when you're a part of a news
organization cuz you you you open
yourself up for liability but podcasts
and people's personal Twitter's they
don't fall under those things and I'm
trying to I'm asking the question maybe
they should in the future because listen
listen if you have millions of followers
you have a hundred thousand over a
hundred thousand five hundred thousand
whatever followers and then you come out
and say some stuff you could say
whatever the hell you want your neck
goes out there to all those people I
mean not everybody watches the news
never not everybody some people just get
their news from Twitter I mean that's
stupid but they do they might see that
like oh my god
did you see this guy was attacked and
all of a sudden it's spreading like
wildfire and in this and and I think
that why what I think is so wrong about
what he did is like in this day and age
in this era with all of the sensitivity
that's going on with all of the things
it's not cool to like you know put gas
on this fire that's already there and
that's what he did it's like you know
what they say about freedom of speech
it's like you can't call fire in a movie
theater because it'll cause a panic and
I think it's an equivalent analogy
because you know what he did was he
flamed that he flamed the fires of
people's sensitivity and outrage and and
it just spread and everybody was like
you see just a what we've done you see
what's going on in the world and then it
turns out he lied it just takes it all
the way it just it's a step back you
know and then the fact that he's not
even getting like there's no punishment
for what he did but we don't even know
all the facts but it seems like Chicago
is a little shady you you even had Trump
getting involved with it like can you
imagine it Trump is along with this you
know what I mean his room you know you
just probably so he's still mad about
Obama being you know from being from
Chicago that's what that is so yeah but
just get anyways I just think that
moving forward I hope people can be like
hey all right somebody said something
let's see what's going on with this you
know with all of it me too everything
aaron ich any kind of allegations
anything let's take a step back take a
measured approach because right now i
think that what he gave he was trying to
take advantage of how dumb social media
is how how the mob he took he tried to
take advantage of the mob mentality so
we should take a look at that and you
know take a mint like i say take a
measure to poach let's take a breath
before we just react to [ __ ] all right
that's my feelings on the jesse smollett
or whatever the [ __ ] his name is and i'm
not even how to say his name alright
let's go to the next name okay we have
brian Hannon let's go to the next two
first up is Cameron Tyler Cameron Tyler
this is a jam give it up for Cameron
y'all okay we definitely need to sing
I need a wand again this is a jam y'all
Cameron Tyler y'all Cameron Tyler make
it [ __ ] all right that was a jam right
there look look how talented people are
like look all the different styles right
man it's crazy
I just next guy this is this is funny
because Russell Peters in the last
episode he mentioned this he made
reference to this song and this is I
gonna mosh to that song it's like the
the original song was like 9900
something I forgot the name with a damn
original song but anyway this next guy
this guy's special to my heart this is
my brother you know my brother from
another mother
I always say to people I go hey yeah I
have her brother Nick I thought you were
only child and I go I am only child but
this is a person that consider my
brother and he made a song for me and he
was so excited to send it to me so I had
it on an episode with Dane Cook and
that's given her from my brother mr.
Cody Cash a Cody Cash a with this little
banger I love the Bell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Cody he just might be gay
I'm just kidding here Cody is gay super
gay but I love him to death he's the
best and that was a jam by Cody cachet
all right so we had Cameron and Cody all
right what's next on a look at their way
from a Griffin notebook you know
occasionally we just go to the singing
Mike for no reason
we own the singing my know see we go
[Music]
that's what we gonna do we just
occasionally gonna go to this thing in
mind for no reason all right here we go
the next up is my Clippers y'all I had
to talk about my Clippers I got my
clipper hat on I got all my Clippers
[ __ ] over here check it out I got my
Blake Griffin bobblehead doll I got my
bobblehead doll right there you know I
got my Clippers piggy bank you know I
got my Clippers pictures my Clippers
hats
guys I'm a clipper fan you know what I
mean and they go into the playoffs I'm
super excited about that even though I'm
gonna be out of town I'm not gonna be
able to see the playoffs but I'm excited
about my Clippers playoffs I mean Doc
Rivers is I told y'all in an episode
like one of my other solo episodes was
all about the Clippers and I told y'all
they gonna have a good season and here
they are they had a good season they had
a great season considering it during the
Western Conference and they're making
the playoffs and right now in the eighth
seed but you know it's it could be a
Thor six and the fact that it would a
winning record almost 50 wins I mean
this is coach Doc Rivers has doing the
coaching of his career he should be for
sure in line for coach of the year so I
hope that he gets the the recognition
that he deserves and I love my Clippers
I've had such a good time going to the
games I don't know if I'm I had the
tickets for much longer
like I share them with Adam because you
know first of all we have four tickets
and we went down because this is just
like we're both out of town all the time
and then they had like this was the
Chris Paul Blake Griffin prices that
they were charging and I'm looking at
the team and I'm like yo like I don't
see this is not justifying that you know
an issue they started playing good price
is still high like it's still at that
point but now we're talking about we got
room for two max players so I know for
sure if we get Kevin Durant or we get
like Kawhi Leonard or Anthony Davis or
Kyrie Irving any of those like big-time
stars they for sure gonna be like well
we know we gotta replace those again you
know and I'ma be like and that that
whatever that team is they better be
playing just as hard like this team
that's what's gonna piss me off if they
gonna raise the prices then they need
these superstars are not gonna play as
hard as these dudes one of my favorite
things about the Clippers is in Lou
Williams and montrezl harrell come off
the bench and they're pretty much the
best players on the team right
like they just the fan-favorite I just
love how they play but anyways I love my
Clippers so watch out for them in the
playoffs and watch out for them for the
future because the Lakers the at home by
Laker fans
alright let's see what we got next year
okay now coming up there's two jams from
I mean these dudes I got to make sure I
get their names right the band name
right but they made the jam of jam for
me already and it's like it's the number
one crowd favorite it's like the the
podcast fans favorite is from detective
designs Rob Kimmel and Eli winterman and
I want to get their band name right dope
oh it's dope APOD oh I hope I'm saying
it right
dope a pod and octave octave cat dope a
pod an octave cat or Octavia hope I'm
saying your guys band name right but
these guys have been jammer from the
start and they made two jams for me so I
hope that the quality of these jams are
good not like the other ones the wav
files but anyway this is from detective
designs and y'all know this one this was
that first jam they
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah listen to the music on this y'all
the talent this funk talent right here
man they can they made this for me so I
can share it with you oh man dude that
[ __ ] is so dope okay that's it
Rob Kim OH Eli kinderman detective
designs octo-octo-octopus at that's the
name of the band and Eli Wonderman is
just like a fantastic musician man he
just he just our music Brighton machine
Rob is on the [ __ ] guitar and all
that stuff and the keys I mean these
guys are great
they're also great designers - Lee you
should check out the take-up designs
online Rob makes a bunch of great
artwork and he's he actually made a dope
t-shirt for me so I'm gonna show you
guys that on the next episodes I might
start you know having some much summer
we'll grab our merch you know what I
mean all right here's the other jam they
made okay so that's the first one
now y'all haven't heard this next one
this is a new one they just sent me and
this one is just as dope - yo and here
we go again
Eli Rob and the band
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah man that's just dope
[Laughter]
that's detective designs guys Rob and
Eli Jam it with that one I love that one
so much so we'll see what we could do
with that one all right last up all my
things I want to talk about of course is
we got to talk about good old Trump
listen guys if you voted for Trump more
power to you if you don't like Trump
more power to you just get involved all
right we've got to get involved now the
thing has come out recently that I've
been haven't talked about because
haven't done solo episodes is like this
mullah report so the mullah report comes
out and what does nothing in it there's
nothing that rises to the occasion of
like let's call Congress and then
impeach him or less investigate further
because you know like two years right
to who your investigation and there's
nothing nothing substantial I mean it's
crazy you know my buddy Ben halls
telling you about when Trump got elected
he was just like on fire he's going to
jail
this guy's a crook like every day he's
our partners our crook my mom was
posting things all the time just like
just anti-trump all the time on the
internet you know CNN MSNBC all they
just they wouldn't stop he's illegal
he's doing is he's going to jail he's
doing that and it's like it's two and a
half years later and the [ __ ]
still president like call me when you
actually have something you know I'm
fight when this guy on Twitter not
really fighting I mean the guy's
passionate and I and I appreciate his
passion because he wants to read it he
wants to see within the mullet report
and my [ __ ] is like who cares why be
disappointed let's just move on to the
election let's move on to vote him to
vote someone in to replace him because
who you're gonna vote for right now I
feel like people hate Trump more than
they support any particular candidate
you know cuz who are the people out
there who cory booker uh who are these
people that are you gonna vote for
Bernie's back listen I love Barney
I like what he has to say but dude he
got outplayed by somebody who lost to
the guy that won like you don't got it
man you and your team you'll it Clint
you let the Clintons bamboozle you and
you didn't fight like you needed to
fight we need some we need a grimy
[ __ ] to beat this dude right we
need somebody grimy and he ain't grimy
enough you know so I don't know it again
like I said who we gonna vote for cuz
you don't vote people out that's not an
option on the ballot of like getting
them out no you have to actually vote
somebody in or does it [ __ ] it's
gonna win again and stop relying on this
mullah report cuz here's the thing
people want to read the mullah report
and then they're gonna be like okay this
is Simms shady here now they don't trust
Muller man but today we're talking about
him for two years about all this is
gonna be it he's gonna drop a bomb this
is gonna be the thing and there's
nothing and so now they're gonna
investigate that and that they
investigate that that's gonna take two
years in that time this [ __ ]
gonna be reelected again
what's the point what's the point of all
of it you know so I don't know you know
how I knew there was nothing when the
lawyer comes to look Cohen
I think the lawyer when he's testifying
right and they don't have [ __ ] on he's
not revealing anything this dude is
going to jail for perjury he's already
going to jail he lied
they got him dead to rights he has
nothing to lose
he should know where the bodies are
buried he gives a check that they
already had they already knew about
stormy Daniels they already had that
check that's the only real solid
information like he said some things but
it's like it doesn't rise to the
occasion of like let's call a special
session of Congress and get rid of the
guy like that's really what people I
think that's what the point of it is in
the first place right but he was
supposed to reveal everything it reminds
me of The Godfather - Godfather - when
Frank paint Angelo he's you know he
thinks the coaling islands are trying to
kill him and then you know so he's
testifying in front of Congress you know
and then in walks Corleone with his
brother he they just look at him and he
[ __ ] knows and easily they're like
with his father we were in olive oil
business and he said nothing that's
exactly what Cohen did Cohen said some
[ __ ] that's like old Trump's race if
people already believe that people
already believe it and it didn't stop
him from getting the presidency so it's
like what did that dude actually do so
when he came up blank when he came up
like it fell short of expectations I was
like uh-oh prepare yourself for the
mother report to have nothing in it and
sure enough here we are nothing so I'm
still waiting to see if they're gonna
like actually release it and we're gonna
see if there are some discrepancies but
here's the thing whoever came up with
these allegations and said like
something's going on with Russia that
was something that was a Democrat and
then they were like oh I think there's
more and then they like okay oh well
that's jumped on it right they're like
okay we better investigate if you need
two years to investigate then is there
really anything I mean anything like do
I really
he like completely I think he's an
opportunist I don't necessarily believe
I mean it's possible but I don't
necessarily believe that Trump
necessarily colluded with Russia I think
he's just an opportunist they already
have proven that Russia tampered with
the election I think Trump got wind of
in it was like oh that's good for us
you know what I mean it's like finding
out you know you're in a race and then
you see somebody's shoes untied you know
that's not good sportsmanship to me is
unamerican like he should have wanted to
win on merit he should have wanted to he
shouldn't want some foreign power no
matter even if it benefited him but
that's who he is he's a businessman all
they care about is himself all they care
about is his own his own well-being so
that when he saw this happen he was like
good good hope they get her and I think
that's what was wrong about it but I
don't think he necessarily was like in
on it you know what I mean but he could
have been but to me I liken it to like
you know you datin a lot of chicks right
you got three four five you know you
date and you're doing it because that's
his business is he's in Ollie he's on
these business dealings he already had
dealings in Russia he was gonna open
hotels
he was already flying under the radar
with a bunch of shady [ __ ] right and so
that's like you dating a bunch of girls
then you get just one bad one she's dope
that's the presidency dope you know you
want to be with discipline but she
thinks she needs you to be it she needs
to know that you're a good guy you're
like oh yeah so you get rid of all these
other ones right but you you know you
still got connections and then and
that's what happened I think that like
all his he's just not qualified to be
president you know he's just not you
know there should be some minimum level
of standard of like you know you're
supposed to give you know you're not
supposed to be such a businessman and
have all these dealings with you know go
do that you were great at that I don't
even know if he was great at it actually
but that's what your life was so don't
do that
now cuz when you're president you have
to be held to a higher standard and I
think he falls short of that higher
standard and these dealings that he had
with Russia as part of it you know you
can't have those dealings and then be
president and then now you have to
backtrack about all these dealings some
I don't know I just think they're just a
model of a rapport thing and this is it
really
we basically to me their mullah report
has basically handed him the second term
so if y'all if your anti-trump out there
you make sure
you rally the troops and get out there
and vote and if you're Pro Trump you
know do the same thing that's that's the
beauty of our system you know let's have
a fair election that's what we want a
fair election no foreign powers [ __ ]
it up let's just have a fair election if
he wins then bull then we'll deal with
four more years and then after that
we'll get somebody new in there but in
the meantime let's just go through the
democratic process all right ah there we
go
so low-rent done okay now it's gonna be
all about the music y'all you know
finish up all about the music so we just
finished with detective designs okay so
now he's gonna be all about the music
for the rest of the episode you know cuz
again I'm really excited about all these
things that people sent in and they
deserve all the appreciation they
deserve all the love because I really
did a great job
so this one guy's name is Eric Rivera he
sent me an intro outro so I'm just play
a little bit of it it's really done it's
pretty dope what's up everybody
[Music]
so that's toe then he made like a
similar one that's an outro so that's
mean the music's just self I mean it's
just oh yeah ok and then ok now this is
my dude right here my dude he just he he
just made a special one for Russell
Peters that was in the last episode so
if you want to hear that one but these
are like these are the fret these are to
the the dope ones that he is made for me
right now and it's Kyle cos mondo pal
quiz mono
I can't listen goofin yeah yeah that's
dope
that's cow cause mundo that's one of the
ones he made for me I love that one
right there and then he also made this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the great cow was Munda that was right
alright then after that okay so I have a
special place in my heart for the next
guy because this is he made the very
first theme song for me that I played on
my very would that I had my very first
guest on the Blake Anderson episode and
so he sent me this and this was the
first time I realized I was like wow
this is like a real thing people really
listen and contribute people want to be
a part of it and this guy
Lamar Landers everybody and I believe
he's gonna be on America's Got Talent so
look out for him he's just like this
nerdy white kid got glasses but he got
just so he got like he got a black dude
in his throat you know well I don't
sound right I'm just saying he got a he
got an old black dude soulful sound
coming out of his throat he's dues dope
and this is the first song he made for
the podcast
[Music]
[Music]
that's my favorite box Lamont Landis is
gonna be on America's Got Talent some is
she looking vote for him that's
like--that's let's get to riffing and
Griffin army out there for Lamont
Landers all 17 of you guys alright um
then he made this other one okay so he's
also the first guy to make like you know
cuz like Kyle made a special one just
for Russell Peters and some people's
made like one for like the Bobby Lee
episode Bobby and his brother but like
Kyle me I'm Kyle Lamont made one for
Jillian and Mary Beth so this is that
money made for them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
SoDo right I coulda put some like
[ __ ] wd-40 on my chair you know I
mean I don't like it that's all over the
place you know
alright so definitely mount landers he
sent two bangers alright next up we got
Marty rugerman this is actually one of
the favors this one's definitely in the
top five this Marty Marty be the smooth
sounds of bloody people
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's Marty be everybody so
there's a fear of if you like Marty be
he only made one song but I think that
songs in the top live for sure okay now
we got another one of my main guys he
does this guy sent me some dope tracks
from the beginning and this is mattock
productions and this is like hip hop at
its finest
is what the kids are listening to these
days and this is from attic productions
y'all oh I don't know if we need to sing
like it
yeah check out mattock productions he's
seen three I got to play awesome today
although
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's Maddie productions okay this next
one this last one that uh mattock
productions made this is the one that
Tiffany Haddish was just lowered horn
she surprised me with that I didn't even
know she could do that but she's just
like I just went with it it's easy
[ __ ] started flowing it was dope but
anyway what I want to do is I actually
wanna have a contest with this mattock
productions beat because Tiffany float
on it I'm terrible at rap and I'm a
playwright now you'll see for yourself
but then what I'm gonna do is at the end
of the episode I'm a player to gain
clean and I'm also have a link on my
website so you can grab it yourself
because I want to see if you can flow I
want you to flow on this matted
productions be give me some reference I
don't give me some rhythm with Griffin
lyrics and let's see what you got you
know but this one was dope this Matic
productions beat
[Music]
oh it's about that time you already know
where oh wait up y'all this is what you
flowin Oh me energy up in the studio
y'all don't know yep I'm terrible it
sound like I could rap right
is that Rick Griffin an eight Lane
Kiffin I wish my dad goes defend this is
one needs Auto wrath it's riffing
I'm not a rapper coming hack if you put
some lyrics in front of me I could read
them I come here I can actually do the
the thing like you know it's like it's
like being able to sing as versus being
able to write music you know I mean I
mean I can like if you not do like you
know it was all the dream are you
through but you know I mean but I can't
like make up my own [ __ ] all right next
up this one's pretty good this is a
totally different style this is Randy
risk free cig I never say his name right
I hope I'm saying - right Randy we see
he came out with this thunderous rock
jam I love this song so much I gotta get
to sing I'm getting the singing mic
before I even started all right singing
Mike for any reason
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we got Randy Randy a super dope I won't
thank way I hope he sends another one
okay then we got okay so now we got
Ricky Martin everybody Ricky Martin not
not Rick not like Ricky what if like
what if like Ricky Martin Ricky Martin
sent me a song that'd be kind of dope
but no it's not that Ricky Martin
Ricky with a nice let's move groove
let's move
[Music]
anyway that was dope the Lee brothers a
episode I haven't even used that one yet
with the Lee brothers but I will next
time I have them on if I ever have them
on again you know ok what we got here we
got two more guys we got two more than
we got in the episode two more next like
next up is Rob pauletta Rob pearl Etta
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good job Rob
let's like see a good one okay and then
last up everybody is my man Adam it's my
just dude Adam Adam herb these herbs on
the internet we actually play video
games with them so I also play video
games I'm if you want to watch me on
Twitch I'm at Eric Griffin comedy on
twitch and I also I'm always with the
worst fire team that's my other podcast
but the worst fire team that's me Eric
cope UFC fighter Steve Lee some of the
time
Pikachu hashtag pika TV that's author
and then of course Craig afros general
Craig corporate Craig TDF Rose he's he's
uh you know he doesn't those are my
dudes we you know we have the time
playing video games together and this is
one of the guys one of our fans
he was started playing with us you know
to me because he subscribed and then he
said hey man you know I actually made
music can I send you a theme song and he
did he sent a dope theme song so we're
gonna finish the episode with this theme
song by Adam and I want to thank
everybody for for listening and
subscribing and thanks for tuning in to
this special episode this is episode
number 26 I've done
I can't believe I've done 26 episodes
and I want to see where it's gonna go I
want to see where I like how the river
with Griffin Studios is gonna evolve I
know that this picture being not
straight is gonna draw people [ __ ]
bananas people this is the kind of [ __ ]
people like gonna obsess over I'm gonna
do [ __ ] on purpose I'm like like you
know you're gonna be like what the [ __ ]
why I said picture not straight but
that's the kind of stuff people obsess
over but I want to fill this with art
I'm getting a backdrop anyways like I
say guys I really thank you for
listening and this has been weird from
with Griffin and let's go out on this
Jam and then remember once again I'm
gonna have a contest with at matok
productions beat I actually won't even
play it after this I'm just gonna put it
on the website
okay so get on that Matic Productions
beat ya'll you don't you don't like it
about it it'll be on the website on Eric
Griffin calm I'll have a link I'll tweet
it out and then you see view which you
can do with it can you flow can you flow
on that beat let me see everybody
descent theme songs hey check it out you
ain't wrong I'm gonna get on that bomb
like Cheech and Chong everything gonna
start rapping angle be no slapping just
party happening cracking cackalacky and
I can't wrap it all so imma sing this
song about rib
[Music]
thank you for listening to me
[Music]
[Music]